(energetic music ending)
- Wow.
From bald to Bald.
Did you see that?
Welcome back.
Sometimes Kelly saves her favorite stories
for the end of the show and she calls it,
This is What I'm Liking.
(energetic instrumental break)
Now, (inarticulate speaking)
I'm gonna go off script here.
I love being on the internet
because I feel like when
I'm on the internet,
I discover new things
and nothing makes me more excited
than watching people on the internet
discover new things.
And this young lady in Illinois
had her kids discovering a brand new thing
which just makes you feel like
they're discovering new things,
at the same time, makes me feel old.
Uh, watch this.
- Yo, it's actually working!
- [Mom] Yeah, it's hooked.
It's a, it's a phone.
- Can I do your number?
- [Mom] Yeah. You, you.
It will ring.
It will call me.
- [Older child] Really?
All right, hold up.
- [Mom] Yeah. It's a real phone!
- What I do now?
- [Mom] Put it up to your ear.
See?
- Answer, answer!
- Oh my gosh!
The phone actually works!
(older child laughing)
(crowd clapping and cheering)
- How adorable is that?
That's so amazing.
It works!
You can hear things and there's numbers.
The girls, Madison and Hayden
are on the line along
with their mother, Leah.
Hi Leah.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Hi, Howie.
- [Howie] What did you like,
did you know they
wouldn't know what it was?
Or did they go to the wall
and say, what is this?
- Well, they've seen the phone before
but they had never seen one that works.
So they were super excited
that it was actually
like they could hear the dial tone.
- [Howie] And young
ladies, were you amazed
when you heard a voice coming through
that thing that you were
holding to your ear?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, It's amazing.
What will they think of next?
Now that you experienced a landline,
do you have any questions, Madison?
- Well, if you're not around
- [Howie] Right.
- the landline like how would
you know if someone called you?
- Okay. So the answer to that is sometimes
like say you go out, say you go to school,
your mom is at home.
So when you get home, your mom
will say somebody called you.
You see how that works?
- Yeah.
- [Howie] Does that answer,
are there any more questions?
I have a question.
Where did your teeth go?
- Yeah.
- [Howie] Where did your teeth go?
(laughing)
You are so adorable.
You really are adorable.
I love that. You're all adorable.
You're beautiful.
Thank you so much.
I am liking your post right now.
Thanks for being part of this show.
But wait, there's more.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of Kelly Clarkson Show,
wanna honor unstoppable,
curious people like yourselves.
So they're giving you
one thousand dollars!
(crowd cheering)
- What?
- They'll be phoning you
- [Mom] Thank you so much!
and letting you know when it'll get there.
So stay by the phone.
Thanks to all our guests this hour.
Terry Cruz, my daughter, Jackie Schultz.
Olivia and Emily Kaufman.
Like Kelly says, have a great day
and if it's not, just change it.
Thank you everybody.
(jazzy outro music playing)